En tus clases de matemáticas elementales,
muy probablemente conociste lo que es un factor,
así por ejemplo, voy a elegir un número
arbitrario, el número 12.
Sabemos que el número 12 lo podemos escribir
como el producto de 2 por 6,
2 por 6 es igual a 12 y dado que 12 es el producto de 2 por 6, podemos decir que 2 es un factor de 12
y que 6 también es un factor de 12, el producto
de 2 por 6 es igual a 12.
Inclusive podemos decir, que aquí tenemos
12 descompuesto en factores,
usualmente la gente no lo maneja así pero podemos pensarlo en esos términos.
Hemos separado 12 en 2 factores
que podemos multiplicar.
Quizás también recuerdas el concepto de
factorización en números primos, en la cual
el número se descompone en factores primos,
así en este caso 6 lo podemos escribir como
2 por 3, y tendríamos 2 por 2 por 3 es igual
a 12, así que en este caso esta es la factorización
en números primos de 12, estos de aquí son
los factores primos...
Así es que la idea general, este concepto
de factores se refiere a los números que
al multiplicarlos resultan en el número original,
o si estamos hablando de descomposición en
factores, como a partir del número original,
obtenemos los factores que al multiplicarlos
resultan en dicho número,
lo que voy a hacer ahora es generalizar este concepto desde la perspectiva del álgebra.
Así si tenemos por ejemplo, una expresión
como 2 más "4x", podemos reescribir esta
expresión como producto de dos números o
producto de un número y una expresión
o producto de dos expresiones, bien, aquí hay
algo que quizás ya viste,
que puedes escribir esta expresión como 2 que multiplica a 1 más "2x".
Y podemos verificar que efectivamente esto
corresponde a 2 más "4x", podemos hacer el producto,
podemos distribuir este 2 como 2
por 1 es igual a 2 y más 2 por "2x" más "4x".
Así es que esto que hemos hecho aquí,
se denomina en términos algebraicos como la
factorización de la expresión,
algo que también se denomina descomponer la expresión en factores.
En este caso, podemos considerar que hemos
factorizado el 2 o también el 1 más "2x",
al final de cuentas hemos descompuesto esta
expresión en dos factores.
Hagamos un par de ejemplos más y luego veamos
cómo es que pude hacer esto.
Simplemente lo hicimos, pero nunca te expliqué
como es que lo pudimos hacer.
Hagamos pues otro ejemplo.
Supongamos que tenemos 6...
no, voy a usar otro color mejor...
Supongamos que tenemos "6x" más...
"6x" más 3... ehhh, ¿qué va a ser aquí?
"6x" más 30, este es un ejemplo interesante.
Una manera de pensar esto es,
¿cómo podemos reescribir estos términos para encontrar sus factores comunes?
Este término de aquí, literalmente es 6 por "x",
mientras que 30 ya sabemos que es
divisible entre 3, así es que esto es 6 por 5,
30 lo puedo escribir como 6 por 5.
Ahora, aquí podemos ver que ambos términos
tienen el 6 como factor común, de alguna
manera estamos aplicando la propiedad distributiva
en reversa, pues en vez de multiplicar por
6, estamos dividiendo entre 6 cada término.
Así es que sacamos el 6 como factor en este
término y en este término de acá.
Con lo que tenemos 6 que multiplica a, primero
es 6 que multiplica a "x", más 6 que multiplica a 5.
Hemos factorizado "6x" más 30,
como 6  que multiplica a "x" más 5.
Y esto lo puedes checar con la propiedad distributiva,
al distribuir el 6 tenemos "6x" más 6 por
5, "6x" más 30.
Hagamos algo un poco más interesante, donde
necesitemos factorizar una fracción.
Digamos que tenemos el caso...
déjame hacer esto con un nuevo color...
Supongamos que tenemos 1/2 menos 3/2 de "x".
¿Cómo podemos factorizar esta expresión?
¿Cómo podemos extraer un factor aquí?
Aquí te invito a que le pongas pausa al video
e intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta.
Te doy una ayuda, trata de factorizar 1/2.
Hagamos entonces eso, si queremos factorizar
1/2 podemos escribir este primer término
como 1/2 por 1 menos 1/2 que multiplica a "3x".
3/2 de "x" es lo mismo que "3x" dividido entre
2 ó 1/2 multiplicado por "3x".
Y aquí ya vemos que podemos factorizar 1/2
para obtener 1/2 que multiplica a 1 menos "3x".
Otra manera de ver esto es...
puedes darte cuenta que aquí, ambos términos
aquí, los puedes dividir entre 1/2 y a lo
mejor eso resulta más confuso cuando tienes
que hacerlo con fracciones,
pero esa es otra manera de verlo, aquí en este caso, ambos términos los puedo dividir entre 1/2...
1/2 dividido entre 1/2 me da 1, mientras que
3/2 dividido entre 1/2 resulta en 3.
Esa es otra manera de verlo, no sé si te
confunda más o te confunda menos, sin embargo
lo que espero que haya quedado claro, es cómo
se hace la factorización de expresiones algebraicas.
Voy a hacer otro ejemplo un poco más abstracto.
Si tenemos "ax" más "ay",
¿cómo podemos factorizar esta expresión?
Observamos que ambos términos tienen a "a"
como factor, así es que esto lo podemos escribir
como "a" que multiplica a "x" más "y".
Y aquí diríamos, que hemos factorizado "a",
lo cual podemos verificar,
si realizamos aquí el producto distribuyendo la "a" para poder obtener "ax" más "ay".